the ending of Transformers rise of the
Beast makes it clear that Paramount
Pictures and Hasbro have grand plans for
the Transformer Saga to finally
Crossover with Hasbro properties but
what exactly future Standalone
Transformers movies will look like is
much more unclear rise of the Beast is
content to tell a largely Standalone
story that mostly exists in harmony as a
prequel to The earlier Michael Bay
Transformers features even with the
Ambitions of using right of the Beast as
a springboard for a Trilogy of
Transformers Adventures it's not
instantly apparent just what aspects of
the dense Transformers Mythos or
Nextbook and relevant this is an
interesting deviation from the last two
Michael Bay Transformers movies age of
Extinction and The Last Knight Each of
which ended on major Cliffhangers that
made it clear what the leaping off point
for direct sequels would be Beyond's the
likely return of Unicron though rise of
the Beast sets its sights on teasing a
larger Cinematic Universe rather than
endlessly hinting at where further
Standalone Transformers movies will go
next either way the lengthy history of
these live-action Transformers movies
indicates that this franchise won't be
going anywhere anytime soon